[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants avez vous été sage
avez-vous je te hais ce que nounours a
été sage
est-ce que nounours euh était au poteau
revenus
tu ferais mieux de descendre voir
nicolas et pimprenelle au lieu de faire
le gros perroquet où ils passeront au
bond le jeune homme popopopop ce
nounours quand même
il a préparé un joli jeu à l'intention
de nicolas et de pimprenelle ou soir les
hommes aujourd'hui
avez vous été sage aujourd'hui thème les
images c'est bien vrai on va faire un
projet ensemble un jeu très amusant et
original
gk n'est pas si on juin à cacher
alors que diriez-vous d'une bonne petite
partie de saute-mouton non alcon est
aussi à quoi on pourrait bien jouer
sinon tu connais pigeon vole nous c'est
abusé oui oh oui un jour à pigeon voile
c'est pas ton jour où tu vas voir c'est
très amusant
voilà j'ai dit des noms d'objets ou
d'animaux et vous devez lever le doigt
costes est un animal ou quelque chose
qui peut voler et ceux qui perdent ils
doivent payer un gage ou oui elles ont
su je sens que je veux connu alosi
pigeon vole piven sa rivale tab le vol
mais nous tu t'es trompé à gages pour
coup dans une table ça me vole pas
canaris vol casseroles non un autre gain
non je n'ai pas de vue la pente mais oui
ne manges tu l'as la vc3 nicolas ce
programme prenant cet envoi ne s'est pas
vrai et puis c'est pas pour tricher nous
nous tue à lever la pâte tout le monde
parle d'un mois tous plus besoin de vue
autre chose et bien maintenant tu vas
payer ton gages qu'elle cache kidman
nicolas mais tu vas le faire tonga le
nom c'est promis oui au droit
le pr je veux faire mon cas tess plus
quoi faire
et bien pour te punir tu ne parleras
plus ce soir si on te demande pourquoi
tu répondras que c'est parce que tu as
triché et voilà qu'on prêts ont pris
sillage ne nous vient pas prône l on va
se coucher tout seuls comme des grands
au revoir nos sources de 8 noeuds
[Musique]
où
le mot
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit les enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents et allez vite vous
coucher à te voilà nounours vous êtes
bien amusé comment ma parole
tu es muet tu t'es pas malade d'une
ourse
je trouve ces patrons je suis plus doux
alors il faut sauter nounours jusqu'à
demain bonne nuit à demain en route nous
noces
[Musique]